Heute im Rasenfunk?
Alexander Schur! Das ist ein Mädchen, ein unglaubliches Mädchen. Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga.
Langhaar fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Schluss vorbei aus, der S ist vor allem das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Der Blick auf andere Jungs Ja, das hättet ihr nicht gedacht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass hier erst der Aufstieg von Eintracht Frankfurt kommt, dann der vom FC Augsburg und dann der vom SSV Ulm. 1848, 46, ohje, da geht's schon los. Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr. Es ist eine Weile her und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier in der Rasenfunk Ligatur, dem Format, in dem der Moderator immer perfekt vorbereitet ist. Die Mannschaften, die wir gerade gehört haben, die haben alle das geschafft, was die Teams, über die wir jetzt sprechen, auch gerne mal schaffen würden. Ein Aufstieg aus der 2. in die 1. Liga. Manchen war das schon mal vergönnt, aber aktuell sind sie alle Zweitligisten und damit haben alle Füchselinnen und Füchse unter euch schon herausgefunden. Wir sprechen heute über die 2. Liga der Männer und ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr, hier eine fantastische Runde begrüßen zu dürfen. Zum einen ist hier Anna Lautenbach. Ihr kennt sie natürlich unter anderem auch vom Podcast Gegengerade von 210. Da ist sie auch immer wieder zu hören. Wir hatten sie auch hier zu Eintracht Braunschweig schon zu Gast. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Es ist wirklich, ich bin so gehypt. Das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen. Das liegt nicht nur an dem Kaffee, den ich mir jetzt noch zu dieser Uhrzeit reingepfeffert habe. Unter anderem liegt das auch daran, dass wir Susanne Vetter hier haben. Sie ist Ressortleiterin Sport bei der neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung. Sie ist außerdem zu hören im sehr empfehlenswerten Osnabrück Podcast Brückengeflüster. Hallo Susanne, schön, dass du mal im Rasenfunk bist.
Ja, stimmt.
Dachte ich, das wollen wir hier unterbringen. Jetzt weiß ich bloß nicht, wie wir vom Thema Enkeltauglichkeit zu Eintracht Braunschweig kommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Anna da eine Brücke sieht.
Nein, das ist der Osnabrücker Spieler, der ein bisschen heißt wie ein Hauptdarsteller beim Bergdoktor. Weil neben Eintracht Braunschweig kenne ich mich sehr gut mit dem Bergdoktor aus. Obfasst würde ich mich lieber über den Bergdoktor unterhalten als über Eintracht Braunschweig. Aber man kann es echt nicht immer aussuchen.
Ja, aber sind die Höhen und Tiefen beim Bergdoktor denn überhaupt vergleichbar mit denen, die Eintracht Braunschweig durchmacht?
Je nachdem, also die Emotionalen auf jeden Fall. Die der Berge wahrscheinlich nicht. Es ist eine Talfahrt. Es ist keine Berge und Talfahrt. Es ist eine Talfahrt, würde ich sagen.
Ist das der Almabtrieb jetzt gerade, der Eintracht? Sagst du uns das, aktuell für alle diejenigen, die es nicht vor Augen haben, letzter Tabellenplatz, 5 Punkte. Also könnte man ja auch sagen, nur 2 Punkte hinter Schalke.
Es ist richtig. Man muss sich da aussuchen, an wem man sich messen lassen möchte. Und gerne lasse ich mich an Schalke 04 messen. Ja, nee, es läuft irgendwie nicht so gut. Also tatsächlich auch bei 5 Punkten ist völlig klar, es können nicht 2 Siege sein. Es ist immerhin einer. Wir haben einmal gewonnen, und zwar gegen Schalke 04. Ja, das war wunderschön. Diese Saison ist die Hinrunde, Mitte der Hinrunde. Und wir haben schon zweimal gegen Schalke 04 gespielt, nämlich einmal im Pokal, da haben wir verloren. Und dann direkt danach, also innerhalb von einer Woche, haben wir zweimal gegen Schalke 04 gespielt, ein Spiel haben wir verloren. Deswegen keine zweite Pokalrunde nächste Woche für uns. Das Ligaspiel haben wir dann tatsächlich gewonnen. Das war schön, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist auch gerade so die statistische Verteilung, wenn du zweimal gegen Schalke spielst, dass du einmal verlierst und einmal... Wahrscheinlich. Aber woran liegt denn das, dass Eintracht Braunschweig sich so schwer tut in dieser Saison? Also so komplett verwundert einen das ja nicht, dass Eintracht da im unteren Drittel der Tabelle abhängt. Da wollen wir jetzt ja nicht irgendwie so tun, als ob das abnormal wäre. Aber es war ja schon sehr früh sehr viel Unmut zu hören. Und wir haben ja auch einen Trainerwechsel schon hier.
Beziehungsweise, ich würde fast über zwei Trainerwechsel sprechen wollen. Nämlich einmal den vor der Saison, weil Michael Schiele, der sehr, also natürlich nicht komplett unumstritten war, weil sportlich lief es durchwachsen. Aber immerhin hat man dann am Ende die Klasse gehalten. Mit welcher Schützenhilfe auch immer. Aber wir spielen 2. Liga und haben die Klasse direkt halten können, ohne Relegation oder so, mit viel Zittern aber direkt. Und dann ist Michael Schiele entlassen worden. Sportlich kann man das sicherlich argumentieren, auch wenn man vor der Saison gesagt hat, wir steigen auf jeden Fall direkt ab oder können uns vielleicht in die Relegation rennen. Das ist dann nicht eingetreten und er ist trotzdem entlassen worden, nachdem er im Januar bis 2025 eine Vertragsverlängerung bekommen hat.
Muss man das verstehen? Also du sagst es jetzt so nonchalant weg, aber …Überhaupt nicht, gar nicht.
Nee, das sind auch alles …Also irgendwie beantwortet all das so ein bisschen deine Frage, was unsere Probleme sind, nämlich alles. Tobi hat mich neulich gefragt, wo ist eigentlich euer Geld? Und ich habe gesagt, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, alle sagen, wir haben kein Geld. Aber wo ist es? Keiner weiß es. Genau, also wir haben den Trainer entlassen. Das hat im Umfeld für sehr viel Unmut gesorgt, weil alles in allem war Michael Schiele beliebt, war zwei Jahre im Amt, ist mit uns aufgestiegen, hat die Klasse gehalten, war irgendwie ein guter Typ. Kleiner süddeutscher Sympath, darauf stehen wir irgendwie. Alles in einem, Grüße nach Darmstadt an der Stelle. Und dann holt man Jens Härtel und kündigt den an, als die Person, die das jetzt irgendwie fortführen soll oder maßgeblich Veränderungen anstoßen soll, steht aber tatsächlich in seiner Philosophie für den gleichen tendenziell defensiven, tendenziell destruktiven Fußball, wie Michael Schiele das auch tat. Also da ist jetzt sportlich irgendwie nichts Revolutionäres passiert, bis auf das man eben den Trainer entlassen hat. Warum hat sich niemandem bisher so richtig erschlossen? Der sportlichen Leitung offensichtlich auch nicht, weil sonst hätte man den Trainer vor einer Woche nicht schon wieder entlassen. Tatsächlich eine sehr kurze Trainerstation für Jens Härtel, der eigentlich wirklich relevant lange immer im Amt gewesen ist. Bei Magdeburg unter anderem und Rostock. Ein sympathischer Typ, der, glaube ich, sich auch zwischendurch wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen gefragt hat, was das hier soll. Ja, genau. Und genau, jetzt haben wir Mark Pfitzner als Trainer. Der darf zwei Spiele, also jetzt gegen Düsseldorf, Freitagabend auf der Bank sitzen und dann das Double betreuen. Nächsten Sonntag. Das wird sehr aufregend, weil Mark Pfitzner unfassbarer Braunschweiger ist. Der war nur drei Jahre ein bisschen in Bremen als Co-Trainer. Und sonst war der nur in Braunschweig. Er hat sogar Bundesliga gespielt und alles ist da geboren und groß geworden. Und jetzt ist er Trainer im Derby. Wenn das keine Geschichte ist. Solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball.
Das heißt, er übernimmt das Gepöbel von Fezic? Oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Ich weiß es noch nicht so genau. Na ja, genau. Es ist alles ein großer Chaoshaufen, der betromt und betreut wird von Vollmann, unserem Sportdirektor, der, glaube ich, als Einziger weiß, was er da tut.
Aber Pfitzner ist jetzt nur für diese zwei Spiele.
Ja, er ist kein Fußballlehrer. Also er hat einen Trainerschein. Aber hat halt nicht einen Fußballlehrer gemacht, und deswegen müsste man Strafen zahlen. Das Lustige ist, es gibt zwei Personen in diesem Verein, die einen Fußballlehrerschein haben. Der eine ist Jonas Stefan, der macht irgendwas im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum, glaube ich. Der andere ist Peter Vollmann. Und jetzt ist natürlich große Aufregung, weil nicht ganz auszuschließen ist, dass damit Marc Pfitzner Trainer bleiben kann, Peter Vollmann sich selbst ins Traineramt hebt. Damit halt diese Regel bestehen kann. Das ist großartig.
Da muss er auch nicht mehr so kritisch mit dem Trainer sein.
Nein.
Wie in einer guten Folge des Bergdoktors.
Sehr gut.
Da möchte Susanne direkt reinkrätschen.
Beim Bergdoktor bin ich wirklich raus. Aber ich wollte einfach nur mal fragen, wie schätzt du denn diese Chancen überhaupt ein und was würdest du dir denn für einen Trainer wünschen? Max, wenn ich da mal so einhaken darf und dir die Frage wegnehmen.
Ich würde mir einen Trainer wünschen, der zum Kader passt. Das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich wesentlicher Punkt unseres beständigen Misserfolgs, dass wir einen Kader haben, der nicht auf defensive Stabilität ausgerichtet ist, sondern angewiesen ist, auf viel Kreativität im Mittelfeld, um Stürmer zu bedienen, so sie denn gesund sind und da. Ja, das ist jetzt alles Polemik, weil ich unfassbar frustriert bin seit 18 Monaten, deswegen seht es mir bitte nach. Ich würde mir einen Trainer wünschen, der Bock auf den Verein hat. Ich würde tatsächlich Motivation und Lust auf einen eher skurrilen Verein mit sehr, sehr schwierigen Jahren über Spielphilosophie stellen wollen. Weil der Verein befindet sich nicht in einem besonders guten Zustand. Es wird immer wieder erwähnt, dass es wenig Geld gibt. Und ich frage mich auch wirklich, warum. Weil es ist jetzt das zweite Jahr in der 2. Liga. Wir hatten wirtschaftlich eigentlich sogar ganz gescheite Abgänge. Immanuel Ferrell ist von uns zum HSV gewechselt für 750.000 Euro. Das heißt, ja, da irgendwas knirscht und hakt. Das ist schon eine ganze Weile. Und du brauchst eine Person, die dem gewachsen ist. Das ist jetzt vielleicht sehr kitschig, aber vielleicht ist es tatsächlich Mark Pfitzner. Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, weil der hat ja noch nie trainiert. Der war ja immer nur Co-Trainer. Ich kann das nicht bewerten. Deswegen kann ich auch gar nicht sagen, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was da jetzt am Freitag passieren wird. Es wird geschrieben in der Braunschweiger Zeitung, dass die Mannschaft in den Trainingseinheiten so wirkt, als hätte sie endlich wieder Lust darauf, Fußball zu spielen. Und endlich wird wieder gelacht. Und endlich haben die Leute irgendwie, so auf dem Niveau spielt sich das da gerade ab. Und auf dem Niveau würde ich auch deine Frage beantworten wollen. Hauptsache, der hat irgendwie Lust darauf, da wieder was entstehen zu lassen. Das Gefühl hatte ich und hatten sehr viele andere bei Michael Schiele. Diesen Funken hatte ich bei Jens Härtel irgendwie nicht. Das ist natürlich auch eine Unterstellung, weiß ich nicht genau. Und deswegen finde ich es immer noch schade, dass man diese Zusammenarbeit nicht fortgesetzt hat.
Das ist übrigens etwas, was, glaube ich, den VfL auch letzte Saison stark gemacht hat. Und auch diese Saison immer noch so ist, dass das Schweinsteiger dieses verkörpert, dass er so Bock auf diesen Verein hat und dass er auch nicht irgendwie über irgendwelche Trainingsbedingungen schimpft und dass es da am Trainingszentrum irgendwie blöd ist. Und dass sie dann vielleicht zu dem Platz immer da hinfahren müssen. Der ist zwar gut, aber dann immer diese Fahrt usw. Sondern dann setzt er sich da irgendwie in Bulli und sagt, so Leute, wir fahren da jetzt rüber und wir machen das und nimmt irgendwie alle mit. Und das ist wirklich eine Geschichte, wo man sagen muss, dass er das halt geschafft hat. Und das ist, glaube ich, wirklich, was du gerade erzählt hast, wirklich wichtig, dass man so dieses Gefühl von dem Trainer hat, der das auf die Mannschaft auch überträgt.
Und gleichzeitig hast du aber auch schon, Anna, mit dem Abgang von Feray ja vielleicht auch einen Hinweis darauf gegeben, warum es eben mit der Kreativität in dieser Saison noch nicht so weit her ist. Du hast gesagt, der Trainer sollte eben zu diesem Kader passen. Wer ist denn im Kader noch da, der solche Dinge tun kann wie eben Feray, also eben offensiv mal eine Idee haben?
Na ja, wir haben eigentlich ein ganz spannendes Mittelfeld mit Janis Nicolaou, das ist unser Kapitän, und Danilo Wiebe. Und das sind auch Punkte, also dahin führt mich Danilo Wiebe, die jetzt in den letzten Spielen so ein paar Fragen aufgeworfen haben, weil der eigentlich also ins Mittelfeld gehört, aber in der rechten Ausauf, der rechte aus dem Verteidiger Position gespielt hat und niemand so richtig wusste warum. Also viele Spieler auf Positionen gespielt haben, auf die sie nominell eigentlich nicht gehören und so was kann mal funktionieren oder aus der Not geboren heraus nachvollziehbar sein, war es jetzt aber zuletzt eher eigentlich nicht. Und ich glaube, wenn du dieses tendenziell schon vielversprechende Mittelfeld zusammenwachsen lässt und zusammen spielen lässt, dass das zum einen für Stabilität sorgen könnte, weil du vor drei Stunden zum Beispiel auch einen Innenverteidiger geholt hast, der vielleicht die Viererkette sortieren könnte mit Ermin Bikakcic, der vereinslos war, nachdem er ein paar Jahre in Hoffenheim gespielt hat. Also auch hier ein kleiner Hoffnungsschimmer in Richtung Kader, der geschwächt aus dem Sommer kam, nach den Abgängen von Feray, Demedina und Benkovic. Wenn man den Blick in Richtung offensive Mittelfeld bzw. offensive richtet, liegen so ein paar Hoffnungen in Florian Krüger, der zu uns kam. Da wurde auch kolportiert, dass Hannover 96 an dem interessiert gewesen sei. Das ist eine qualitativ erstaunlich hohe Range. Ich hoffe, dass er noch mehr zur Form findet. Er ist jetzt ganz neu im Kader. Er braucht vielleicht seine Zeit, um sich da zurechtzufinden. Robin Krause ist ein absolut wichtiger Akteur. Durch sein Auftreten, seine Emotionen, sein immer wieder reinarbeiten und reinkämpfen, genauso wie Fabio Kaufmann, der vielleicht nicht immer das glücklichste Füßchen hat auf der einen Seite, aber der beständig wütend ist über diese furchtbare Situation, in der sich der Eintracht befindet. Das schätze ich sehr, weil ich glaube, dass vielen von uns die Energie fehlt, diese Wut irgendwie aufrechtzuerhalten, dass sie aber wichtig ist, um sich da unten rauszuarbeiten. Was halt einfach fehlt, ist ein Stürmer, den haben wir. Der ist Anthony Uccia, der hat sich verletzt im Spiel gegen Nürnberg. Das war unser einziges kleines Hoch. Wir haben gegen Schalke gewonnen, dann zwei Unentschieden, beim zweiten Unentschieden, das war das 2-2-2 gegen Nürnberg, hat er sich die Schulter verletzt und seitdem haben wir nur noch verloren.
Und wie ist jetzt der Ausblick für Braunschweig? Es ist alles wie immer kompliziert, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt. Die nächsten beiden Spiele jetzt Fortuna und dann dieses kleine Spielchen gegen Hannover. Da wird man sich ja jetzt noch nicht mit befassen. Jetzt geht der volle Fokus auf Fortuna Düsseldorf. Das merkt man auch dieser Runde hier. Da hat man das von Anfang an gemerkt, dass das wirklich unwichtig ist. Sechs Tore hat Braunschweig erst erzielt. Nur Wien-Wiesbaden hat mit neun Toren noch eine einstellige Anzahl. Alle anderen haben schon deutlich mehr Treffer erzielt. Aber Anschluss ist ja da. Und wenn ich mich an die letzte Saison erinnere, da war es zwar so, dass man eher das Abrutschen verhindern musste, aber da war es doch auch so, dass zwischenzeitlich Braunschweig mal zumindest auf dem Relegationsplatz war. Und man hat es ja dann immer wieder geschafft, wenn auch mit anderem Trainer und so weiter und so fort. Hast du ja alles schon erklärt. Ist das jetzt vielleicht auch nur gerade eine hoffnungslose Momentaufnahme?
Ich wünschte, ich könnte Ja sagen.
Es geht ja nicht über die Lippen, man hat gemerkt, wie du kennst.
Es geht mir nicht so richtig über die Lippen, muss ich sagen. Ich kann halt wirklich überhaupt nicht einschätzen, was jetzt passiert. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, welcher Trainer geholt wird. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass irgendwie noch Gelder aufgetan worden sind, weil sonst holst du auch einen Ermin nicht einfach so oder nochmal zurück. Also der spielt ja auch nicht umsonst. So Herzensangelegenheit, die Stars, alles schön und gut. Ich finde einfach, dass dieser Sportdirektor wirklich nicht mehr da sein sollte, um einfach langfristig meine Idee zu entwickeln. Weil lieber steige ich mit einer langfristigen Idee ab, als dieses langsame Sterben Jahr für Jahr zu ertragen. Es ist wirklich, wirklich schwierig. Was gibt uns Hoffnung? Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Also es hängt wirklich total von dem ab, was jetzt passieren wird. Weil unter Jens Herpel, hatte ich gesagt, da ist keine Entwicklung in den letzten drei Monaten passiert. Unser bester Spieler steht im Tor. Unser zweitbester Spieler ist bis Weihnachten krank. Ja, und jetzt mal gucken. Also ab und zu gibt es Spiele, in denen erstaunlich viel funktioniert, in denen es auch spielerisch absolut ansehnlich ist. Irgendwie sehr attraktives Kurzpass-Spiel. Viel funktioniert, nur die Tore nicht fallen. Und wenn jetzt diese berühmt-berüchtigte Spielfreude vielleicht wirklich wieder Einzug erhält und die jungen Spieler Selbstbewusstsein gewinnen und sich noch mehr an diese Körperlichkeit in der 2. Liga gewöhnen.
Ich muss sagen, ehrlich gesagt, ich kannte schon deine Meinung und du warst ja auch zuletzt im Rasenfunk, hast ja auch kein Blatt vorm Mund genommen. Aber der Begriff langsames Sterben, der hat mich jetzt schon ein bisschen unvorbereitet getroffen, muss ich sagen. Weil ist nicht eigentlich Braunschweig jetzt die letzten zehn Jahre da, also immer am selben Ort, nämlich irgendwo zwischen 2. und 3. Liga? Und natürlich fühlt sich das anders an, wenn man so eine Saison erlebt und das zwischendurch dann auch in der 3. Liga mal nicht so gut aussieht. Aber dann schafft man den Aufstieg usw. usf. Aber eigentlich hat sich doch da so allein von der Tabellensituation hier gar nicht so viel verändert. Ich gucke, der Aufstieg aus der Regionalliga war 2007, 2008, seitdem immer 3. oder 2. Liga.
Ja, ich glaube, diese 10 Lieberknechtjahre, das hat uns einfach, das hängt uns immer noch so ein bisschen nach, weil das einfach so die große Liebe ist, an die seitdem nichts mehr rangekommen ist. Du denkst aber, es ist halt so, wir tindern halt im Moment, aber es funktioniert nicht. Wir haben immer noch so ein bisschen Liebeskummer. Klar, es ging auch schon wesentlich schlechter. Wir sind halt wirklich fast in die Regionalliga abgestiegen. Das war einfach unfassbar knapp am letzten Spieltag mit irgendwie einem Torunterschied gerade so die Klasse gehalten, in der dritten Liga. Insofern ist es verhältnismäßig okay. Und du merkst ja den Braunschweigern so einen gewissen Pragmatismus an. Also du gehst halt hin und steigst ab. Und es findet klar, wir sind alle genervt und wir hätten es gerne alle anders. Aber so richtig schlimm findet es glaube ich inzwischen noch keiner mehr. Weil es halt die Eintracht. Aber was mir halt fehlt, ist die Idee. Also das, was Susanne gerade erzählte, wofür steht der Verein. Was ist die langfristige Idee, auch davon abgesehen, dass man sagt, man will die Klasse halten. Und da fällt mir leider im Moment nicht so richtig viel zu ein. Und das tut schon ein bisschen weh. Und das ist das, von dem ich halt gehofft habe, dass es vielleicht unter Schiele wieder wachsen kann, dass du halt an Eintracht Braunschweig und an irgendwas denkst. Und das stellt sich halt irgendwie nicht ein.
Aber immerhin wissen wir jetzt, wie die Bergdoktor-Folge zu Eintracht Braunschweig heißen würde. Tinder gegen Lieberknechtkummer. Komm, ich nenne die ganze Folge so. Ihr drei, das war sehr, sehr interessant, amüsant und zum Teil richtig emotional. Das hätte ich gar nicht erwartet zu dieser späten Stunde. Es hat unheimlich Spaß gemacht, mit euch dreien auf eure Vereine zu blicken. Und jedes Einzelsegment hätte hier noch eine Stunde länger gehen können. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank euch drei. Danke Anna Lautenbach. Ich drücke dir die Daumen, dass du wenig Liebeskummer mit Eintracht Braunschweig in den Neck vertragen musst.
Danke Susanne und natürlich danke Tobi.
Ja, dann müssen wir jetzt auch als Nächsten Tobi danken, dem, der sich schon in zwei Wochen so auf dieses Derby freut. Ich bin so gespannt. Ich meine, ihr wisst es ja noch viel besser als ich, aber es sind schon so viele lustige Dinge passiert, auch unerwartete Dinge rund um diese Derbys. Aber erstmal danke dir Tobi, dass du hier mit dabei warst und mit deiner Podcast-Stimme auch hier im Rasenfunk vertreten warst.
Danke für die Einladung. Danke euch drei. Ich hoffe, ich konnte die Stimmung so ein bisschen nach oben treiben mit meiner zwar neuen und irgendwie noch ungewohnten Euphorie, aber zumindest mit guter Laune, was den Blick auf die Tabelle angeht.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass ich dich mal als gute Laune-Onkel zu irgendeiner Sendung einlade. Aber hey, ich meine, wir sind jetzt im zehnten Jahr. Irgendwann musste das auch mal passieren.
Es muss sich auch was ändern.
Und ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Es war ein fantastisches Debüt. Susanne Vetter, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Und natürlich allen noch mal empfohlen. Brückengeflüster, da kann man dich viel ausführlicher noch holen. Danke dir, liebe Susanne.
Jetzt habe ich mich nochmal verhaspelt zum Schluss. Euch auch noch einen schönen Abend. Danke für die Einladung, Max, für das Debüt. Ich wollte nur sagen, das Derby steht an, aber Anna danach spielt dann der VfL in Braunschweig. Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja dann mal live vor Ort.
Das hängt vom Derby und von Tobis Trinkkräfte.
Anna, der November ist wirklich in Hannover, zu Hause gegen Osnabrück und dann beim HSV. Das ist November, wie er im Buche steht.
Ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen. Ich freue mich auf die nächste Bergdoktor-Staffel.
Das kann man sehr gut verstehen. Für alle diejenigen, die das jetzt nicht bei YouTube gesehen haben, die Motivation, an die Bremer Brücke zu fahren, sprang Anna förmlich aus den Augen. Also wirklich alles an ihr schrie, ja, da habe ich Bock drauf.
Erst in Braunschweig. Bremer Brücke ist in der Rückrunde.
Mensch, da gibt es ja nicht mal einen Grund, sich das anzugucken. Aber hey, ich habe gehört, auswärts kann Osnabrück nichts, Anna. Also hab Hoffnung.
Wir sprechen uns danach oder davor.
Genau, und bevor das jetzt hier in der Therapiesitzung ausartet, danke ich euch dreien nochmal. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da draußen ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Empfehlt diese Folge bitte weiter. Sagt anderen, dass es dieses Ligaturformat gibt. Ihr wisst ja, wir sprechen über die Europäischen Ligen hier, über die zweite Liga. Und das eine oder andere wird auch in den nächsten Wochen hier noch so noch mit reinkommen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für euren Support. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubundkiosk.rasenfunk.de sind die wichtigen URLs dafür. Und ansonsten schaut auf rasenfunk.de, was es sonst noch so gibt bei uns. Macht's gut, bis bald.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr KNAUSA.